ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tan importante es de humanidad
que pudimos llegar a la luna que pudimos
explorar gracias a que un mundo de
mentes brillantes
se animó a explorar lo desconocido
gracias a que la humanidad tienen sus
genes en su adn el querer explorar el
querer soñar el querer buscar más allá
de lo que vemos a nuestro alrededor
pudimos llevar a un ser humano a los
confines inhabitables en el espacio y lo
más importante fue que lo regresamos a
salvo
el día de hoy quiero platicarles una
historia estoy aquí para contarles
porque los mexicanos
o las empresas mexicanas necesitamos dar
un cambio estructural un cambio
organizacional
para poder ser mejores cada día
quiero presentarles muy breve
quién es la empresa
soy tijuanense tengo 26 años
actualmente tengo un socio es lindo
creo que muchos tijuanenses tenemos
socios que son gringos entonces
quiero contarles esta historia
nosotros no nos dedicamos a crear muros
nos dedicamos a crear puentes a traer
oportunidades a méjico oportunidades de
trabajo oportunidades que le ayuden a
los mexicanos a explorar sus límites
aquí en esta imagen quiero compartirles
en la fotografía dónde se encuentran las
dos niñas
dos niñas que tienen tres años y se
están animando a soñar es tan importante
que nosotros como mexicanos estamos
teniendo la oportunidad de soñar estamos
viendo la oportunidad de ir más allá y
de seguir construyendo los sueños que
las nuevas generaciones están pensando
diferente entonces por ende las nuevas
empresas tienen que ser diferentes
no tenemos que adoptar los dogmas que
teníamos antiguamente las empresas las
empresas tienen que empezar a cambiar
tienen que empezar a modificar tienen
que empezar a entender cómo funciona la
nueva generación de seres humanos vamos
a llamarle
años atrás
era inimaginable
que una persona de origen indígena de
origen nahua pudiera ser un ingeniero y
que pudiera llegar a ser desarrollador
de software en apple computer hoy es una
realidad tenemos mucha gente en el
extranjero que está brillando que está
teniendo
una misión una visión que quiere traer a
méxico a compartirnos esa esperanza esa
esperanza de que no estamos solos esa
esperanza en la cual necesitamos del de
los demás para poder crecer
hace poco tiempo bueno hace tres años
para ser exactos platicar con mi mamá y
le decía mamá algún día
quiero hacerlo grande quieres mirar a
los demás quiero
que la gente me escuche y quiero que la
gente tiene a mi mensaje
mi mensaje es que los mexicanos
hemos estado bajo la sombra de los demás
por muchos años
porque no nos atrevemos a decir que no
porque no decimos que los mexicanos
estamos hechos para resolver problemas
claro que si estamos hechos para
resolver problemas pero lo más
importante es que estamos hechos
para hacer un cambio
cómo lograr ese cambio es muy chistoso
porque
recuerdo
recuerdo que
inicie esta empresa y dice mi sueño
y como lo dijeron anteriormente no él
el primer inversionista es tu papá y mi
papá me invirtió muchísimo en la empresa
invirtió muchísimo mis sueños
pero yo tenía una misión tenía una
convicción entonces cuando apuntas a dos
personas que tienen una visión y una
convicción
qué es
igual que tiene un objetivo las cosas
suceden cuando estás queriendo
contribuir a una sociedad en la que la
sociedad
si tu empresa se vuelve de una manera
altruista y que me refiero altruista
altruista me refiero con devolverle algo
a la comunidad me refiero con qué
con que los mexicanos vayamos a pensar
más allá de las cosas que no únicamente
los mexicanos podemos triunfar en el
extranjero
en la construcción sino que también los
mexicanos podemos triunfar en diferentes
áreas y que podemos ser los número uno
no siempre podemos estar provocados
perdón por lo que por lo que hace el
vecino sino que debemos entender que en
eeuu muchas de las empresas nos están
buscando porque nuestros genes tenemos
esa capacidad sobre problemas porque es
que logramos desconocido porque hacemos
las cosas con pasión porque tenemos
extremadamente pasión para hacer las
cosas y cuando tenemos esa pasión
podemos descubrir áreas que a las que a
las cuales nunca hayamos llegado
anteriormente entonces es por eso que
ahora necesitamos un méxico inteligente
y cómo lo vamos a lograr abandonando
ciertos dogmas de las empresas antiguas
en las cuales estábamos acostumbrados a
hacer dinero detrás de las personas eso
ya no es ya no es lo que necesitamos en
méxico ahora necesitamos empresas
necesitamos personas que contribuyan a
un cambio social a que cambio me refiero
al cambio en el que las personas sean
transparentes de línea a línea ve de que
nos atrevamos a hacer ese cambio
como punto importante que me gustaría
mencionar
es que nosotros vamos a tener sueños
que soñamos largo que soñamos fuerte
que soñamos aquellos lugares donde no
podemos llegar
quizá en ese momento pero no te puedo
decir que nunca
entonces está bien soñar
está bien tener sueños lo que no está
bien es tener esos sueños y nunca tener
una meta hay que tener una meta
y en esa meta
se convertirán
en el objetivo en el objetivo al cual
queremos llegar en el cual queremos
formar un cambio dentro de la sociedad
algo que quiero invitarte
s que tomes este ejemplo
de un astronauta
de que te juntes con personas que tengan
una mente brillante que tengan esas
ganas de ser algo increíble esa pasión
esa energía por querer explorar lo
desconocido porque es muy fácil hacer
las cosas es muy fácil ser el proximo
steve jobs o crear un nuevo facebook o
decir que eres emprendedor el mundo está
lleno de emprendedores este mundo ya no
necesita emprendedores este mundo
necesita gente que quiera explorar y que
quiera explorar lo desconocido
ahora pareciera que
lo imposible podría no ser tan imposible
que podemos lograr las cosas pero lo
vamos a lograr como te lo dije
anteriormente
teniendo esa pasión teniendo esas ganas
teniendo esa convicción trabajando
diario
eso es lo que para mí es importante
y eso es lo que quiero tras transmitirte
a ti
quiero que
sientas entiendas que veas que hay más
allá de las barreras que este es el
futuro de méxico es el futuro de un
méxico inteligente que entendamos que
los mexicanos no estamos hechos para
decir que sea todo que no podemos estar
trabajando fuerte y trabajando duro para
tener éxito para tener para para lograr
lo que queremos una vez escuché que para
tener todo tienes que trabajar muy
fuerte tienes que trabajar arduamente
hasta alta ser de noche para ser exitoso
tienes que trabajar como nadie pero
quien se preocupa por trabajar
inteligente empecemos a trabajar de
manera inteligente empezamos a cambiar
la manera en que hacemos las cosas
nuestra sociedad
lo requiere nuestra sociedad nos está
pidiendo un cambio nos está pidiendo que
tengamos esas energías esa pasión por
hacer las cosas
entonces
hay que devolverle a méxico lo que le
fue secuestrado hay que devolverle a las
personas esas oportunidades esa paz esa
esas ganas de crear algo importante esos
ganas de querer hacer algo y de
pertenecer a algo importante no
únicamente el hecho de que quieran ir a
trabajar o no únicamente el hecho de que
vamos a hacer algo porque porque
simplemente lo quiero hacer y me va a
pegar porque es lo que quiero no
hay que ser cosas importantes hay que
hay que ser diferentes hay que ser
mejores que el porcentaje
siempre son mejores que el día de ayer
hay que invertir en las personas
no teman invertir en las personas
hay que invertir en nuestros sueños en
nuestras metas en nuestros objetivos
seamos parte de aguas de un cambio
generacional que estamos teniendo
hay que seguir adelante hay que
levantarnos con esas energías porque hoy
es tiempo de soñar hoy es tiempo de
crear hoy es tiempo de impulsarnos hoy
es tiempo de hacer cosas increíbles pero
sobre todo hoy hoy es tiempo de tijuana
hoy es tiempo de eso tijuana que quiere
levantarse hoy es tiempo de méxico
quiere ese cambio entonces te invito a
que explore de lo desconocido y que
lleves este mensaje a todos los rincones
de méxico porque méxico necesita eso
explorar lo desconocido gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]